animal crackers on a Tuesday and vlog 29
[Music]
so when we look at a map of the world we
see countries countries divided up by
very neatly drawn lines lines which have
a nice sense of finality to them right
this land belongs to this country and
that land on the other side of this line
belongs to that one of course we know
that the geopolitical reality is
anything but as conclusive as these
lines suggest we know that there is
civil fighting contests ations of land
and ownership local loyalties local
hatreds religion sex and factions who
can and often do flip their noses at
straight lines drawn in comfy rooms by
foreigners at some time in the past
we've come to use in our global parlance
the word nation-state to identify these
places it's a term we don't think too
much about we use it freely without
going to our dictionaries but the truth
is of course that nation-state as a term
quite often fails to adequately describe
many of these countries where for
example civil war is a continuing
reality so maybe by pulling the term
apart we can get a better understanding
of how these two words nation and state
can come together now the state is what
can be defined by lines on a map the
area over which the state central power
called the sovereign has control the
sovereign in theory has a monopoly on
all the violence that occurs in the
state and on the international stage the
sovereigns voice in theory is an equal
among other suckers this is the basic
definition of sovereignty equal abroad
master at home it was Jean Bodin in the
16th century who first laid out these
characteristics in his six books of the
Commonwealth thereafter Boden and others
having worked at its use tried to figure
out where the source of sovereignty live
but I believed as was the custom of his
time that the sovereign then ruled by a
king or Prince was derived from God and
political thinkers for the next two
centuries continue to find the source of
sovereignty in divine right or in the
laws of nature or social contracts but
by the end of the 18th century a
revolutionary new idea came to the fore
it said that the source of sovereignty
lay not in the man upstairs but in the
many men and later women
in other words the source of sovereignty
was in the people you see it loud and
clear in the very first line of the
Declaration of Independence when in the
course of human events it becomes
necessary for one people to dissolve the
political bands etc etc one people in
other words one nation by this time the
word nation had become synonymous with
the word people so here you have a state
which finds the justification for its
sovereign power the monopoly on all the
violence that happens within its borders
in the consent of the people the nation
hence nation state the question becomes
how do you define a people what makes
people a people we have a number of
problematic nation states in the world
places couched in what seems like
unceasing violence and to understand
them we must first understand how people
develop a national identity now there
are a number of things that groups can
share a language race a religion but
stronger than all of these is as John
Stuart Mill the great liberal thinker
said an identity of political
antecedents a possession of a national
history a community of recollections
collective pride and humiliation
pleasure and regret connected with the
same incidents in the past a historical
narrative a national memory this binds
people closer together than any other
common trait unfortunately and as we
know too well the many millions of
people who find themselves in a state
very often don't have the same memory
narratives diverge are rewritten mixed
with myth and fiction as the years and
decades pile on all of a sudden you have
one state with two people's or three
people's and the problem grows it took
four hundred years and a lot of blood
for the island of Ireland to resolve its
issues between nation and state wasn't
easy Catholic Irish and Protestant Irish
have very different memories of a
national history full of conquest and
subjugation in 1921 the largely Catholic
southern part of the island declared
itself independent from Britain the
Protestants being largely of British
descent and who held power in the north
had no desire to break from the UK so a
partition was built separating the Irish
Free State from North Ireland good
solution right keep the warring factions
apart the only problem is that the
Catholics still in North Ireland became
an ill treated my Nord here's a map
showing the distribution of Catholics
and Protestants
in North Ireland doesn't really suit
straight lines on a map does it
fortunately in 2007 the Irish troubles
were settled peacefully however this
kind of conclusion isn't really the norm
though there is a partition for example
on the island of Cyprus the northern
Turk Cypriots in the southern Greek
Cypriots haven't yet come to the same
kind of conclusion because the issues of
nation and state there haven't yet been
resolved nor have they been resolved for
Kurdish Muslims the largest single group
of people in the world who don't have a
state of their own
now we know of course that many Kurds
live in the northern part of Iraq but
few if any identify themselves as Iraqi
the example that we're perhaps most
familiar with is that of Israel and
Palestine we know the history and we
know how each party writes the narrative
and who's to say which is right just
last Saturday was landing an annual day
of Palestinian protests for an event in
1976 in which the Israeli government
planned to expropriate thousands of
Palestinian demands for security and
settlement purposes one protester was
killed more were injured and sent to
hospitals what are the remedies when you
have two peoples living in a territory
to which both can lay claim territories
which are a part of their history their
family history well you can have
external forces come in and try to
referee the situation but we've seen
from first-hand experience how imperfect
such solutions can be
how about partitions like in Ireland or
Cyprus difficulty is there's always
going to be people on both sides who
think the partition is unfair what about
population movement a kind of ethnic
cleansing where one people has to move
to another place it's a solution but an
extremely painful one in which those who
are forced to move lose everything
all of these remedies are not lightly
taken but the sad truth is that they are
often better than the alternative which
is endemic violence that feeds on itself
lessons here are feeble but maybe this
is the most important one violence of
this kind produces precisely those
experiences which pass into history
confirming strengthening the identity of
both sides worse violence of this kind
produces people with the stake in it
continuing namely young men to whom such
civil war becomes a way of life
providing a source of employment
excitement adventure and most
importantly purpose sovereignty is a
problematic thing it can often produce
deeply depressing results but if there's
one thing that we can do as an
international community
it's to try to understand the history
and example of such cases to try to
foresee and prevent new antagonisms
before the violence that consumes them
becomes a self-generating monster well
she actually managed to keep most of
them in